[Musique]
le 7 avril prochain c'est vraiment mes
coups de cœur merci mais ça veut dire ma
maison la maison la maison de quoi vous
dit vous parler le plus ça parle de mon
identité de famille ou que j'essaie de
me réapproprier
parce que mes drop ça peut être
n'importe quoi ça peut être quelqu'un ça
peut être un territoire ça peut être une
place ou je me sens en sécurité et bien
fait alors ouais c'est un peu sur ça
[Musique]
démarche c'est que vous mélangez toutes
sortes de musique ensemble oui de la
musique un peu plus traditionnelle mais
aussi la musique hyper moderne vous
qualifiez derrière vos chansons de mais
aussi de punk c'est quoi votre approche
le concept de cet album là j'étais dans
un gros trip de fesses j'étais aussi
dans un trip de
j'aimais beaucoup Billy Morton
des artistes des artistes féminines qui
s'assume dans ce à faire du
Duroc ou du punk et tout ça fait vous
avez 24 ans tout a commencé pour vous à
magnoténamment la musique est venue à
vous
je pense la musique est déjà dans ma
newtonome elle est déjà dit est vraiment
on le ressent pas mais elle est quand
même là il y a une vraiment une énergie
ou créative là-bas par exemple je pense
beaucoup à beaucoup de personnes on joue
de la guitare là-bas à cause que
ils ont été inspirés par Florent Volland
et précédemment avec qui acheter une
aussi et
le accessibilité
quand même proche aussi de l'accès
facile et proche de d'un studio dont le
studio m'accusham de Florent volant et
Matthieu mécanzi je pense qu'il y avait
l'accessibilité l'influence c'est aussi
l'acceptibilité de
d'accueillir aussi des artistes avec le
festival inonicamu et aussi
la radio communautaire qui diffuse qui
diffuse beaucoup de de musique
mais il y a des gens quand Florent
volant qui veulent instaurer un quota de
5% de musique autochtones dans les
radiocommières qu'en pensez-vous
je pense que c'est un bon moment je
trouve que on va vraiment permettre aux
auditeurs de vraiment comprendre que il
en manque pas de la musique en langue
autochtone et ça existe et c'est le cas
par exemple quand tu quand on regarde
dans la plateforme numérique
on voit qu'il y a plusieurs musiques
dans les dans plusieurs langues
autochtones ça devrait être vu comme on
partage on partage le même territoire
puis je pense que c'est là qui c'est
avec ça que je pense qu'on va peut-être
créer comme plus
une plus grande
ouverture plus une plus grande aussi
comme connaissance de que dans quel
territoire nous sommes
[Musique]
sur mes choix vous chantez en français
et en inouïmoun et vous vous
réapproprier les nuits d'une certaine
façon vous le réapprenez qu'est-ce que
ça vous apporte d'apprendre justement
les news ça m'apprend un petit peu plus
sur qui je suis en tant que femme ou
puis aussi de comprendre un petit peu
plus un peu les valeurs de de des Inno
puis parce que je pense la langue est un
peu une la vision de type même c'est la
même chose avec le français et puis
nous permet aussi de comprendre aussi
c'était quoi on va dire
la vision de cette langue millénaire là
comment
[Musique]
comment c'était quoi les traditions et
tout tout est dans la langue et tout ça
revient cannelle aidez-moi à terminer
cette entrevue je vais vous dire merci
en inouïmoun alors comment je fais ça
chez moi on dit
bravo
[Musique]